[Music]
hello everybody and good morning welcome
to GameSpot live it's Friday
usually it's community Fridays but
pitting Gianluca very busy and important
folks so a rich he and I are back back
at play some more call of duty modern
warfare beta with you guys and they also
dropped some fresh new Friday content
which is awesome you can see here they
have a new map and a new mode which is
what we're gonna play mostly today which
is cyber attack um and yeah Tim beaten
map in there the new gunrunner map yeah
the new gunrunner map in there also I I
think I might have played on that map
not sure yet this morning yes alright I
hopped it couldn't help myself of course
Wow no gears our monster on her sad face
I know I'm sorry Brandon Ben and John
Luke definitely really really wanted to
play some gears with you guys today
they're making a lot of good content
first yeah exactly Tube channel and
they're all swamped right now yeah I'm
so busy so they're just stepping in help
but no worries no worries always next
time but thanks for tuning in anyways
yeah so this one's kind of interesting
it's remind me of like Search and
Destroy mixed with sabotage mixed with
you say kill kill reconfirm yeah but in
a different way like you can revive your
TV instead of just picking up their tags
nice so you have one life technically
like you'll get knocked down and you're
just spectating and then if your
teammates pick you up then you come back
but if your old team gets eliminated
then the round is over oh man yeah it
sounds pretty breezy
it's good it's fun I can't wait for this
game says check Alan yeah oh man are you
on the beta yet try it out hoping this
weekend it's still only for 300
people who have pre-ordered
story mode I don't think that
give us access No yeah we don't have a
early copy of the game we're just
playing the beta like the private beta
we want story mode
[Music]
so I hid
so we have to care about our lives and I
saved my you
our YouTube channel started gaming it is
there all types of trailers on Aarn II
there was so much hype for that treasure
I love that trailer location price back
it's too far too far this is the hot
zone I'm gonna go around I know I got
killed way too fast last time I think
I'm above the action right now Oh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh no Holly so it's all me love the game
sounds as Douglas so do we I think I do
I think you do too right actually mine's
a little loud oh my game perfect thank
you yeah thanks
Seibert I love kicking kicking doors
open we got one of theirs oh no you're
what's up crime and everyone tuning in
happy Friday mom's right there they
probably have eyes on me oh good work I
know I'm the College website they have
all of the specifics laid out Oh wrong
button okay
Oh No
calmly open this door quiet
these look maybe I can revive this guy
great that's where I need a beef is not
this bomb still the only sniper I hate
that guy somebody take care of him my
teammates how many maps in about access
to I think it's four or three four and
then maybe I think yeah there was one
attitude but I think it's a total of
five look again yeah
what's good everyone so chilled thanks
for joining us
the one in the mountains and then the
new one which is kind of like a yeah oh
man maybe I should snipe
I got snipe so bad last time oh yeah
he's probably posted up again huh but
Amen I wish I could Pina something I
really like about apex I can still semi
communicate oh no
I'm gonna try alright
okay so neighbor is not in this building
the Sun they have one left
I watched him die oh man okay you when
does the pc beta come out not this
weekend not the following weekend but
the weekend after it'll be open for Xbox
one users PC users cross play included
hey chill so - like I haven't seen you
in a while I was going for attack oh
okay that round that we did good we
can't lose gotta keep it up I keep dying
I realize we didn't even play any
headquarters we did huh that's its own
like playlist
I noticed it I noticed last night after
no I do
I see I'm scared me to move should be -
[Music]
be like he sniped me so close look at
this is ridiculous so rude can't wait
the graphics look badass as frat they do
I'm watching your street you got it
though you got some help I felt like
that guy was standing there the whole
time that's the one that got me - can
you show how to half open the door I
mean if you like bust down the door when
you run into it breaks open and it's a
double door then you can close one door
and not the other that's yeah that's one
way the double door like kind of
peekaboo like but you can soft open any
door if you just walk up if you're not
in a sprint like this and just kind of
hold the door to open well that opens it
all the way actually yeah yeah I don't
know if you can leave it a job yeah
there I just kicked it there were like
three of us in that building no one not
one of us aw dang it
hey laser what's up even if the game
like munitions for everyone here is your
reward no where is the last guys one
more guy and he's gonna snipe me watch
all you just revive someone no I kind of
like the that aspect of it
me too except when it's happening - I
think they're bomb planting exciting is
clear here we go down to one
I'm just breaking open air no entry 20
seconds
no yeah woohoo
well it's still 3 3 its first 5 that's
true we got this round win yeah an open
an open beta for a whole week would be
pretty clutch that's how they're getting
they're teasing yeah they want you to
pick up the whole game there i preorder
it already that's how i got this baby
yeah that's the max data so far no
just running it all the doors yeah
thanks so much noise so many times where
I jump scared myself cuz I watch in
front of a door yeah
I think I told you yesterday that the
door slamming makes like more noise than
the gun over there most of the time if
I'm just walking into the door it
doesn't open unless it like I actually
pulled down right where it'll come
running it automatically just knocks
open every door sometimes I'm oh really
it's from sprinting I am and they have
an enemy UAV up dance around me same
team can shoot each other you can and it
doesn't really do any damage but those
characters are still like we're on this
yeah they may call out to you shoot
friendly fire watch your fire that's
very funny
alright let's try the Dora thing just
walk into it I feel like that hasn't
worked we got to get to the door before
I see me just walking into a door is
that with yeah this evening because I
know for me it does like I kicked you
open all right find another one yes yeah
I'm walking in there right now you
actually press square to open it
that UAV is bad news I'm gonna try to
clear the sky of it if I can find it I
am using the classic Disney ghost and
it's
so helpful because that guy just ran
right past me where is this UAV again
dizzy over here okay I'm gonna try the
door look just walking into it
no go at least not for me that's the
other thing about seeing like all the
footsteps on the scene like enemy and
friendly so I'm just paranoid 24/7 yeah
oh boy everything's black and white yeah
they have one left
oh no that's smart I was gonna go in for
the are you know I would go in for the
kill you there you go oh no he got our
friend thing I was not it was upset whoa
okay I was scared but I heard him
running rain capped at 10 yes so far
yeah max level is level thing which is
why I'm use
one of the standard classes actually
because it has goes right you can get
that's smart
I just want to be cou that song this
game guys look yeah this game is it's
got some static feel to it let's see oh
I should have picked that other class
well it's too late I can't respond yeah
I got a hold that until the next round
now you're back oh nice slide great
effort
you were like surrounded that's where
they put the bomb basically we were just
trying to get out of there definitely a
turning point for the cod franchise once
again after a decade yeah I guess it
really has been that long since there's
just been so many cons yeah they didn't
stop making them that's for sure but man
first a fire ruff yes what mode is this
its new yes this is the it was launched
this morning called cyberattack yeah so
you only get one life you can be revived
however you have to plant the bomb find
the bomb plant the bomb yeah it's like
Search and Destroy and sabotage and a
little bit of Apex legends with the
revive of your teammate I kind of like
that though because I did play a lot of
Search and Destroy in the older Cod's
and once you die you're dying yeah sit
further around you sit there in your
soul I think that's what kept me from
those modes I like I need the respawn
I'm a I'm a rusher so I get killed a lot
but like I am I good games I kill a lot
too but I don't know Search and Destroy
I need patience and I just don't have
that very much PC gamers will kill
oh yeah rescue trying to remember always
I've only ever really remember
search-and-destroy hmm
dang it couldn't beat them all no hey we
remember oh yeah the cross cross upon a
cross platforming will come
two weeks
new map okay yeah here it is the new map
guys oh boy you know for some reason in
I've clean we look at one spot for like
ten minutes and then all of a sudden no
one's there and the second you look away
is someone there we go quick win easy I
didn't really get to even explore the
map blackops2 you in mind where first
you take and I think although I do it's
growing on me it's growing like the
first few games I played ever of the
baby oh man
feels clunky but then I started seeing
how they change things like they gave
certain perks as pros and cons to
attachment shotguns as opposed to like
you know at a perk yeah they're all
dairies have to buy them differently you
know are they there
they changed the way you use them or how
you implement them Wow yeah crime we
were like yeah that is fast
yeah we're watching Ritchie's feed at
the moment which is sorts but turn it up
to where we could switch back and forth
so we may we may we may do that at some
point yeah it's all good
Matt Padgett in the chat ayyy oh he says
the mash baby has split up between
controller and keyboard a mouse only PC
players using a controller for two three
come on
although yeah no one's got the bomb yet
green leaf yes the level captain is
still at level 10
[Music]
that's okay I'm gonna save it
what's your favorite gun at the moment
you know I was gonna say that in for a
woman who's got the fifth one I have
been using the most but now I've been
using this ghost glass the ensemble it's
doing pretty well for me and it's
silence which you'd usually like nerve
some of the damage but it's been working
out and for me no surprise that I've
really been liking I got jump scared on
my walk to work today about this big
18-wheeler and honk this morning no and
I literally like yes all right I have a
very important question can you see your
feet never
oh wait I can see my feet oh you can
that's cool you do the backward search
okay no way am I being revived I don't
deserve it
all right saving my last the last round
of saving money maybe four cool okay
what round did we just finish that was
round
oh boy Oh so killaby dead silence is in
the game but it's a field upgrade it's
not a pro concern so it's something that
will charge up and then you can use it
after it's charged up and then I'm
assuming it'll go away at some point
maybe I don't know I'm not sure this
crash boy but we can level up - Wow oh
dear I almost dead I can move there we
go
Wow
I barely made it out of that one I
thought I was gonna lose it
yeah the odd the field hog is back I
can't unlock it but it's one it's one of
the pre-loaded classes so you can use it
there we go
I like rarely ever hit anybody with -
there's a lot of indoor spaces that
don't allow from especially in that cave
map I feel like more than half of it is
out there that's funny you were able to
see your feet I guess that's something I
never really thought to like pay
attention to I thought it came up before
that's why I was like no you never have
boots I felt like that was just the
thing he's right though
[Laughter]
you know taken seven seasons visas
I'm really liking the feel yeah at first
I was just capturing some matches late
for us and then I was like man I
actually really like this character date
got one and his friend was there they're
literally all rats
DFO else Annette really taking it back I
love me some DFO I actually played it so
much before they took service down and I
was really - they brought it back but
they'd like you couldn't bring back your
old profile really they wiped it on that
it's still an amazing game female I'm
being called out here it
oh man this is I knew there was gonna be
a guy can be in there I knew it oh you
got it's always funny to because you go
to the Killa cam and it's just someone
like standing behind a barrel 80s for
like a minute straight until you reckon
that's it that's a you know it's still a
strategy love it or hate it especially
in a game mode like this where you just
swear you can die with I guess you know
dead silence not really being accessible
right now and it up the data too so you
got to work with what you got the bomb
was going off to keep it quiet yeah off
the radar here we go okay so I for a
tank
get to that device anyone else in chat
playing this over the weekend the beta
goes on till Sunday 10:00 a.m. but only
people pre-order oh wow you're right I'm
going back out there
oh he was behind AI swarmed y'all you
injured yourself with that uh-oh that
fire you know
oh yeah they were all just oh it was
just me out there y'all attack the new
plants vs. zombies and this Call of Duty
beta all right got your weekend set my
friend oh yeah we still pre-order games
because any of you again access to betas
like this yeah what I'm really hyped for
a game how to go pre-order in every game
but they're still oh my goodness sorry I
had a there we go my friend took care of
them right there shoot somebody died
right here oh here we go
stick with me I was inside the the main
garage
that wasn't you left on their team we're
not even going okay going for it we
can't have him reviving anybody I know
he took us somewhere else and he to go
me definitely I was like a missile now
so thanks for watch out oh great you're
right yeah the killstreaks way for a
breakpoint to come out all right we got
a breakpoint Dan Austin wants to drop a
nuke before the debate it hopefully you
don't let us unlock it there just 30
kills poof and I don't even know if it's
uh actually don't know if available in
they don't play man that's gonna be the
same we had the same idea okay I'm going
around
Oh
gilberto rockin yeah no okay he's in the
room where the bomb is he said right way
actually now that I'm like oh someone
picked it up okay good
I was wondering if the bomb spawn in the
same point every time okay am i watching
yeah I am the wall yeah you fire a
little bit I don't like I don't think I
like that type of grenade okay someone
Oh someone got one of us mmm out
I should revive someone I'm gonna go
back there's someone over there by the
bomb come on oh we have to them one okay
okay all right all right see me meet him
at his own game
he was just sitting there looking at the
door oh yeah takes a camera you knew
where he was
that's the plus side playing objective
man we can only camp so much like if
some of your whole team's down your last
one there's so much eating my favorite
cod of all time horse ooh
that's a tough one by I'm probably gonna
see DoD for good old shootie for ya
classic I think mine was I have mine
worker 2 got one only basing that on
multiplayer experience oh that's true
yeah I like the whole modern warfare
series as a whole for sure it stands out
the most to me is the most memorable
yeah oh he's still down there oh so dark
is yeah the main garage where the bomb
is I think yeah in there nice yes
killaby says black ops 2 all day
yes very good multiplayer close ok they
have one left
you just took down one of my guys oh
we're fine follow this goal that open
this door quietly and then my teammate +
sin
oh we got him
Ethan said cod4 was my first Cod nice
choice know what same I didn't get into
the agree with killing me and cecelio -
you like black ops 2 is a very close
second for me I loved like all the
customization options and you can like
make your own little icon everyone oh my
goodness for better or worse honestly I
literally took off and jumped over
oh no okay there's the bomb okay the
plant area is over there that's that's
so hot right now like that's where all
the shootings coming from I don't want
to plant it yet although they have one
person left I'm going for it yeah he's
near me oh I put the bomb down and
even why oh really oh okay cool we won
by okay I don't know how I made it out
of that one I actually killed them on my
very last bullet oh god it's so bad that
used to be a challenge challenge
complete favorite cod are cod for
favorite moment I mean the whole last
chapter that whole game is excellent
but I don't know multiplayer moment it's
just playing it man I don't know the
cross play mouse and keyboard is
controller to be well I know the Mac
earlier mentioned that they are gonna
separate the cross play from personally
after recent events I guess specifically
eight extraction see there have been
these tournaments linked to tribals and
stuff like that and there has been pad
players playing against people on PC and
winning to like they're good
Oh two to three we got to revive some
people too - okay good stuff oh the
other guy is if he doesn't kill this guy
he's outside with you they're reviving
to reopen for blackout Moe don't want to
work there like a battle royale if it's
there yeah I'll try it out but you don't
need to put that in there for me I'm
saying like apex is enough for me they
kind of took over your way out okay they
have one left
bouncing betty that lead i to it oh the
proximity meiyan it's been different
here we go all good though we're up now
oh no don't let them take up they're
good players no Frank says controllers
have a misis call it even I won't
disagree it's very helpful can't do much
about that
however the class I'm using I think
makes me like invincible too
oh really yeah belly tactical master
whatever no it's on that gross class
yeah I think I'm gonna pick jack both
class you're selling it to me here final
round
oh I know I know wait I have some items
I've been using that goes class okay
great
well have munitions I have to wait six
seconds surprise
noise all right I see two people in the
back and two people in the building with
a bomb
finally yeesh
oh boy oh boy okay the bomb is right
there twenty-two people brush that we
can't let them revive and please don't
let this guy get ya yes sweet bye let's
go one day the our players BR this is
Frank actually Villar would reign
supreme just actually I played that John
wick VR game Farrell wasn't that tight
very it's pretty great it's got how's
your experience with the game so far
there's things I like and things I don't
like and the things I don't like are
mostly just me being a spoiled brat for
instance like there is no real
difference in the way like your
teammates feat sound and the enemies so
I'm constantly getting psyched down
again not a huge deal just me being
spoiled you didn't like see the outline
of your teammates no matter where they
are like through buildings and stuff and
there's been a few times where they just
so happened to be standing like
somewhere far away and their outline is
covering a door and then someone is in
that doorway and it like messes with
what I can see that is a new addition so
I'm like oh that's like kind of annoying
but also like seeing the outline I'm
digging it so far yeah but everything
else I actually actually like a lot so
in general I've been having a lot of fun
with it
this kind of looks like counter-strike
no that's not the first time we've heard
that today even get some counter-strike
vibes
there we go all right I like this map
I'm on the fence sometimes I do really
well and sometimes I just get destroyed
me too but uh I feel like it's I was
like cool use the mp5 it's like a cave
there's lots of short lines of sight
it's not like that this is a very like
the enemy same Oh three two three come
on who's got the bomb I think it's open
yeah someone dropped it I mean sniped at
all in this game I'm just not not a good
sniper would not make for good content
can you lean be up against something
then it'll prompt you it'll say just how
you can lean and press where I believe
it does I forget what bun it is first I
thought it was like r1 something more
easy than I expected from what everyone
actually still forget I'm laying this
for since yesterday haven't even wanting
to get your wallet cuz I run around too
much they let me go up to this long is
this another fast to die call duty game
I mean the way the way I play Oh how'd
you figure it out are you it's because I
play tactical this would not work for me
cuz I'm assuming the mountain is r3 yeah
you will go up to the wall 80s but I've
got a practical so my mouth I know it's
it's toggle though so I guess I forgot
you played tactical yeah cuz I am a drop
shot scrub scrub okay these people were
around here dang someone went down yeah
maybe I should focus on the bomb huh no
no oh that tactical slot oh shoot mother
North ass is this another fasted I FPS
game again if it's recent but I don't
think with as fast so it's like the
older gods used to be
there's still been time crying
still took like three or four shots
besides yeah it felt fast though I don't
know wait try that ghost class again
oh yes the bunny hopping honestly I
always associated bunny hopping with
like cable but I've been seeing so many
people do it in this game that it's good
or not because I don't intuitively think
to jump in this game when I play me
either people still do it ever since
old school players still do a halo but
then be people like port and I love to
jump I'm somewhere in the middle where I
just don't even played on bumper was all
about finding optimal strengthen numbers
maybe I should just go and revive patrol
just reviving everybody you Syst oh yeah
owes you it actually tells you you saved
it oh but then I died too low oh yeah he
has a high divinity
was he killed someone else I think I'll
go for it
Lipton no with that I knew it he was
going for it is the Indian Party got any
good I don't know I always mute people
when I like go in but the few seconds I
do hear people chatting I don't know if
there's anything like it'll be kind of
choppy I use it yesterday with just the
party of me and one other guy and it
went well like that the party if you
want to be you know outside of a chat
room
jumping makes me visible on Team
Deathmatch I don't know that that's true
that's great because I don't like when
people jump I'm always jumping over
stuff oh well yeah something like
bolting over something is fine but like
just jumping to a boy to kill in a
gunfight I don't know any call-out so
I'm like whereas if I'm gonna know great
I'm in the wrong class and I have my
Rockets I meant to pick up the bomb bomb
Murray vibrating me
Frank can an enemy take damage from a
door being kicked open not that I know
ooh think about that no I'm pretty sure
I kick the door open writing some guy's
face and it didn't do it grass enough
for a text I used to use like the
PlayStation party chat yeah I use that
to where the audio comes in clear let's
roll yeah I keep forgetting to switch my
class oh why they let me okay in that
case someone shot me bro oh nice you got
the bomb
Oh No that's what I get do any weapons
feel opt right now oh pretty balanced
also they're actually maybe a little too
similar sad Chad oh yeah watch that
flank Oh me here grenade oh wow what a
klutz play I wish that was me that was
fun I know right
yeah no use need more guys like Chad
here I know
Gold okay that was awesome that was no
thanks to thank you thank you
where's Chad he's your left yeah I wish
I can remote like leave
right I can't even inspect my weapon
that kind of stinks that was awesome all
right we have the channel the dad Chad
all right yeah we all could be a little
more like Chad you know he has like a
missile
he has a UAV up I'm gonna try to wear
yet they're all on the toast oh it's an
allied cruise miss okay that was lucky
and I got do you think the FAMAS living
nerve
I mean most of these companies are open
to hearing that out if people say the
FAMAS needs to be nerfed or the FAMAS
nice mean earth then my right now I
don't because you know something that's
always been a thing in cars like firing
SMG has always been him revived Chad we
have Chad and then we have five revived
errs I want is I need to add him as a
friend yeah you just you want someone
like this on your team I have to hate
the fact that I had to wait till the
19th see that was just caught things
like there he's looking at that door
watch the replay and then the second he
decided around
unload on ya gene that play earlier from
Chad was dead you got it
I'm just gonna follow him now I don't
want to drag him down I can't do that to
Chad no don't run next to me you guys I
am a ghost
[Applause]
this guy is ruining my ghost-like
tendencies yeah no one's been hitting
the cave so far they're wiping us out
y'all gotcha Jojo although that's
probably my last kill because it's okay
people keep walking oh that's so scary I
hate that we are playing on ps4 pros the
tools I have one left
we're still alive
how are the recoil on the guns I think
they've been okay for me so far kind of
kind of low but like
wild but once we which once you like
actually attach some things to it I kind
of felt like the Pumas on burst was a
little him it's a single fire and it was
a lot better okay okay I've been with
the as much but you know I noticed a lot
of the attachments that they offer now
in the gunsmith mm-hmm are very specific
they do have some specifically for a
vertical recoil horizontal recoil that's
cool no this is like a replay of last
time me and homie are in the cave over
here hmm they took out my friend I'm the
only one x mountain warfare meme quote
we all need a Chad says Eric I know can
all just be Chad's
no we don't need to see days I know what
happened they're everywhere
oh we're getting a request to see your
feed Persia are you down yeah alright
alright we got you switch some things
around now I apologize in advance know
where the massacre yeah yeah you want no
way I'm pretty sure he's doing better
than me for two days that are all you're
doing great oh yeah oh yeah okay cool
alright we've switched we've switched so
hey it's not quickly we are playing
cyber attack mode fresh off the presses
happy Friday a fraud all this awesome
content
we got you we're on the Persia feed now
perchik ham oh boy I see you need to no
longer manually rejoin like in black ops
for it kind of pushes you in a new hobby
every time that is true Jean Maura you
don't have to manually like inject
yourself or heal yourself but there are
different perks and things like what's
it called like tactical equipment and
stuff like that that can slow down your
healing process so there are ways to
kind of mess with the healing a little
bit for your opponents I'd like that
we are here to destroy the enemy data
center use the EMP wipe the slate clean
I hit a little wine tactical but I'm too
chicken actually oh oh that scared me I
was like was he just waiting for me to
pick up my team oh you know what I never
plugged myself back into my control only
your gunfire I'm doing great so I might
just go without it like I don't need by
all my sensors Oh crud
as soon as I say that I guess yeah yeah
cool he was downstairs
oh yeah psyched out meeting me where is
this guy he booked it oh I actually do
realize there was a door there there's
one left week we'll get another tour of
us let's go plant the bomb go plant the
bomb you guys this guys must have a Chad
bomb in on us no yeah is that Chad on
the other team I know we left that let
me check we yeah we miss Chad oh he's
camping the bomb he's camping the bomb
he's is this you okay I'm up there
channel my inner yes yes we channeled
the Chad miss Cod it takes two more
regular beat downs but you can add a
muzzle attachment that cost that makes
it one bead on oh that's cool so they
kind of replace certain things with
where's this UAV I see nothing but
seagulls okay there we go we got the
advantage
and neither could he was using oh no I
got a cruise missile oh yeah
Terry Crews inbound oh he's indoors was
perishing because I wasn't ready using
the ghost class too because he wasn't
highlighted red he was for me oh yeah in
my view it just looks like that oh no I
had a square root and eagle eyes
switching sides fine without an inch at
my friends only play first-person
shooters on PC good movie how popular
this map is rough
[Music]
be like no channels a chat so I'm
reviving someone in some way they got
him down again son of a bleep
okay I should have had that wall risk
pass this game by any chance take place
in Florida I don't think so although I
don't know copies worldwide baby you
know the ping goes everywhere yeah
making all the movies where you at I
being revived no way it is me okay they
have to we can do this we got this now
they're one math tells me we have an
advantage
slide a hand on my m4 class it's it's
pretty good I guess the lack of accurate
[Applause]
soldiers now they're all like doctors
bringing us back wait I'm a medic so are
they calling a search-and-destroy sniper
attacking fighters there some difference
there are a few differences like
reviving me I think that's the biggest
one now you can revive now I'm dead and
in search one site would be odd since
once I would be defense and now it's
kind of like sabotage a bomb and two
points
well I got three P's come on it wasn't
that close to each other but I still
call it a three-piece I did nothing
ironic that a runner back in like halo 2
I was trying to level up like 42 because
nothing is the knife so good Arthur nice
Oh God in this game it takes two hits
now it's a more of a melee with your gun
and not a knife oh the tactical knife
though there is amazing tactical knife
and I think there's like an axe or
something to cool the regular melee
though it's alright it takes two I feel
like I haven't been using it oh yeah let
me show you guys what I meant by house
it has like pros and cons you know like
this is muzzle attachment that enables
one melee hit you know so it's like it
takes two but with this attachment and
the good thing about this one's there's
no cons like this one
the cons you're aiming guns sagginess
goes down your ATS goes down it's a lot
more layered which you know if you have
that run and gun style you don't want
you know to have a slower like aim down
sights and all of the you know the
sights to reduce your 80s speed as well
which is interesting but yeah here's my
sleight of hand perk and the other perks
there is to a game here and then yeah
like even the grip certain things
there's a con to it but this one
improves your ATS feed and your sprint
so fire speeds so it's like why wouldn't
we allow it now sounds amazing
robotic ASEC the graphics
hideous a statement yeah first time for
it so far actually what games do you
like what games are in the whole world
but it's a nice realistic upgrade for
everybody secure the EMP and destroy Z
and Ravana Center with a capital C
where's your where's the fire where's
the s'mores there's some sort of
tactical grenade and talking and try and
shoot but when they throw it if you're
in the vicinity it will show whoever
threw it so there's a small radius and
it's like and they can see through the
walls like you're like how you can see
the teammates you'll light up yeah okay
I did light up and it was like someone
spotted you if I think that was yeah
okay for sure for you had to live
through the wind
what's up Adrian Larry nice to see ya
been a while did they stop caught
Pawlenty a sniper bullet still don't
when we first started this morning I got
a quick scope to my face and he was so
close it was like embarrassing I'm
hearing gunfights two friends
I like reviving it's so helpful yeah you
can really turn the game around
I was hoping if I just open the door I
like a civilized human being no one
would notice the second I did like
someone turned her out on ya the name of
the operation that is the name of this
map right this game-mode is called laser
attack right Frank thanks for stopping
by if you're heading out thank you for
joining us
yeah thanks for tuning in weekend every
weekday 11:00 a.m. Pacific time thanks
man there's a lot of doors
could be back
so we did go through a grenade right
underneath my lab that's just where it
landed Friday - your lunch
with love from South Africa what up RN
thanks for joining us guy great
yeah we're still up by one we got this I
wish I could get a kill streak but I
keep yeah I'm no I'm going out I'm
impatient with that kind of stuff and
it's harder for me in this mode when I
die and there are consequences
I just can't respond
we're all kind of playing like TDM and
we should be alright y'all are
distracted over there like a guy on top
of the crate
oh Christ over okay we're hanging out in
the afterlife yeah we are
now it's time are there any pricks that
make your character do less call-outs oh
that's a good question because funny
yeah if you're reviving the characters
like oh my god you I wonder if they hear
that though I've heard others oh yeah
yeah I've heard the other team really
loaded yeah that's a good yet where's
like the silence Berkeley yeah the trap
should know cause yes you running ghosts
STFU enjoy play bro
maybe no thanks
still a ghost I'm ghosting oh no they
got I am liking this there's a lot of
ways Oh No
is there story mode in this Kruger we
are it's confirmed for sure and there's
everything but not in the beta
we're all waiting for oh I thought he
was like actually chasing me but any
chance you guys also stream the
battlefield game I have before
right now this is hot limited this
weekend but you know when battlefield
comes around play whatever is happening
or what's going on just like stuff
that's pretty irrelevant makes me like
really reach for angles to play things
like Tetris 99 does that deal see you
guys it's like dealer's choice on Monday
you should do that it's like purchase
choice heck yeah we playing all of like
the wackest craziest games that's better
for a while okay let's do retro
Wednesday's where I just play something
like that yeah but you know whatever is
hot when it was trending we try to cover
it for sure
63 to that area over there by the crates
of scary please yeah that's where this
guy took out like two of our guys okay
Daniel Daniel hi all what up man
oh yeah the night vision goggles we're
saying there was a night cave version of
the map I still have not played um no no
it's not in the beta but at the call of
duty event like yeah you know exclusive
yeah I didn't even go I just cut the
gameplay from Aaron Sampson who oh yeah
um what is it okay so there's sign of
the Creed's kill that guy but a missile
came from the heavens
oh I definitely out of habit tried to
ping and I caught myself on fire toward
freedom we are playing on ps4 pros of
both of us I tried it last night on
okay I did to my regular piece Brown
yeah
is there any battle royale coming
tomorrow warfare it's been rumored I'm
not gonna confirm on anything but at
that moment there's nothing telling us
that in the beta Vice location confirmed
gold out the odd is a nice gun I'm
mainly using this you got the sailors
here in a hunt all the way in the back
or did they actually push out of their
base got a real oh I miss chat already
I should have revived my teammates
lattice robotic which there is no
free-for-all nominator fire it'll be a
full game but it's not available this
weekend Oh
why no they have that giant ground war
right there was no yet no no I supposed
to be the last weekend there is a 20 the
20 mode but there's also going to be a
32 v30 and an alien device courageous it
should be available the last weekend of
the beta I think I finally holy smokes
you got him I got all three
anyone look what is that a chopper
yeah everything we channeled the
chapters you know any start taking
damage and your sprinkle is black and
white I don't know why but I always just
feel like I died I guess when I get shot
color fades from my vision I've never
been shot before bless bless thank you
Bob Jones yes personally you got most of
the kills right
I think our teammate might have had the
most kills that time yeah at least one
of that one that guy that corner to you
or maybe even two right I mean that last
little play in that last round three
people came through and shot remember I
was saying you look into the spot
forever in the second you walk away I
was staring down this door and I was
like I know this door is here then I
went picked up the bomb and I heard the
door open so I rushed you down there
three people there you're right some
things just don't change all right looks
like we have time for one more game of
cyber attack just drop today yeah just
drop today and the cool thing about this
beta is that as the weekends go on
they're like giving us more stuff
they're raising the level cap they're
you know putting the beta on more
platforms so it's definitely a pretty
good faded you ask me just to round up
all the information in pre-order
Modern Warfare you can play this weekend
the beta is open to Sun next weekend
play only on ps4 then final is open to
ps4 players Xbox one PC that will be
available everyone did we lose yeah yeah
what me where are my friends I want to
revive you all where can i preorder some
teammates through the wall no one
revived me to the wall I'm doomed guys
Shh that was me kicking the damn door
open my sensitivity / good but you know
some perks will actually slow down your
80s speed because you might think oh
this is a sensitivity issue and you'll
change your sensitivity and there will
be a super fast when you're not in a
Dias so oh yeah count anyway yeah we'll
see
as my options the voice location compose
I'm actually surprised as I play on
default now because Iceman I actually
way back in the days play on one and our
whole team is chilling in that one
revived duty everyone I
noise 2v2 noise early download not that
I know if you had to have pre-ordered
too early download this weekend arts you
play the beta this weekend when was that
like a c4 I think the bomb went off I
already said it but I heard the bomb
take flavors are great
yeah I love them though but I can't
unlock them in this unless you use that
guy that pre-loaded class that's right
umm yeah you should be able commercially
you're available right now cuz I haven't
I just went just like being a ghost
the beta will drop the laundry order
people next weekend I believe beginning
next Friday maybe even Thursday it's
kind of a good meet like hey pre-order
you can play it right now right now a
whole weed yeah a week yeah actually I
had to play the beta this weekend so I
already pre-ordered fortunately um
should be and also pre-ordering on ps4
specifically oh that's for ps2 closed
beta for people on ps4 who have
pre-ordered the game for attack cyber
attack and I think if you did pre-order
and download the beta and you open it
and you aren't able to access it will
tell you I know before this one was
available
what can you do if you're all alone man
I couldn't channel the chat I was like
she just so [ __ ] cuz going everywhere I
ran okay he was seeing black and white
though bang you know this was not a
diverse team you were doing great before
oh well since Chad left hasn't been the
same
[Music]
I feel like our team is very defensive
and they're very awesome so they're
rushing us encouragement from chat you
guys got this that's something about
this game that's a little different
there are more opportunities to like
climb up onto something and then over a
wall whereas like the older ones can
play do that right yeah Trash Can that
was actually just at our clan tag should
be Chad I'm with it
I'm down team Chad team Chad team Chad
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with us today on a Friday we're having a
lot of fun with the beta it's gonna be
out you know for kind of a while it'll
be continuous throughout every weekend
this month pretty much so if you've
pre-ordered you can play this weekend
but next weekend if you have a ps4 you
can play for free it'll be open oh yeah
and the weekend after Xbox users PS PC
users everyone can join it'll be
cross-platform noise until next time you
guys we'll see you later have a happy
Friday and a wonderful weekend and come
back next week weekdays at 11 a.m. PS
see you GameSpot live it be happening it
be going down you already know where to
go alright we'll see you guys later bye
you
you